hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast advancing neuroscience
functional insights from in vitro
microelectrode array i am dr. stacy
kobato of axion biosystems and i'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by action on bias axiom
biosystems is a life science company
focused on solving problems related to
human heart and brain activities we have
commercialized the first multiwell
microelectrode array platform the
maestro which you will hear more about
shortly today's webinar is focused on
neural applications using the maestro
and we will hear from some great
speakers doing cutting-edge research in
pain and autism applications we have a
few announcements before we begin please
take a moment to answer the poll seen on
your screen
we're just trying to gauge your level of
awareness and MEA technology this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left
I would now like to introduce today's
speakers dr. Daniel Millard is an
application sciences that act and
biosystems he will provide a brief
introduction to mei technology and the
maestro platform next dr. Carol marketo
from the Salk Institute will speak about
using the maestro's to explore network
level signaling in an in vitro autism
model then dr. John Graves from
bristol-myers squibb's will present on
pain modeling using dorsal root ganglion
neurons I will now turn it over to dr.
Daniel Millard for an introduction to
MEA technology and the maestro platform
hi everyone my name is Daniel Millard as
Stacy mentioned i'm a senior application
scientist at Actium biosystems and today
i'd like to give a brief introduction to
micro electrode array technology and the
maestro mea platform and how these tools
can be used for advancing neuroscience
and neural applications first I'd like
to start with a brief review of some
recent trends in life science
instrumentation first is the development
of stem cells as tools which has really
enabled us to get human biology in a
dish faster and better than ever before
also the these tools the stem cells
being used as tools has has led to a
resurgence of phenotypic screening and
in particular the use of disease and ish
models to take human disease phenotypes
and mimic them in vitro and then finally
the use of stem cells and other cellular
models for drug discovery and drug
safety in toxicology has led to a
significant animal reduction which is a
government mandate by a number of
organizations in the world together
these trends highlight the desire to
model complex human systems in vitro and
there's a number of reasons why we would
want to do this and the first is the
ability to take complex biology these
key biological variables for
electroactive cells such as excitation
inhibition intracellular signaling and
gene expression and be able to map those
key biological variables to function in
microelectrode arrays provide a direct
measure of function for electroactive
cells by measuring the electrophysiology
that arises as these key biological
variables are are manipulated in the
cell culture a microelectrode array is
based off of a technology of embedding
microelectrodes into a substrate of a
dish such that cells can be plated into
that dish
sell then integrate directly with the
electrodes and also with each other so
that the electrode array can track
individual action potentials and their
propagation across the network an
example of the raw voltage trace that is
detected by the electrode was shown
there in yellow and with and by doing
some simple processing we can detect the
action potentials extract them as the
extracellular action potential waveform
such that each electorate of detecting
activity from one or a few cells now
with the microelectrode array where we
have multiple electrodes within a well
we're able to capture the activity from
not just one electrode but multiple
electrodes in this case we have a four
by four grid of electrodes with each
electrode detecting action potentials
from one or a few neurons located in
close proximity to the electrode there
are numerous advantages to having
multiple electrodes within a well with
the first being the ability to sample
many cells as opposed to just a single
cell and this allows the
characterization of connectivity across
those different cells within the network
leading to truly Network phenotypes and
the ability to quantify these four
neural applications and this
significantly enhances the reliability
and reproducibility of the data as Jason
mentioned before the maestro is the
first platform to combine microelectrode
array technology with a multiwell format
with an industry-leading 768 electrodes
distributed across 12 48 or 96 wells
which uses with each of these
multi-electrode array plates being anti
compliant and interchangeable with with
the maestro recording hardware in each
of these electrodes is multifunctional
and what I mean by that is that each
electrode can use to both record the raw
voltage that is elicited by the
electrophysiological changes of the
cells but also to stimulate or activate
the cells nearby the
the electrodes in addition there is a
heating plate underneath the microplate
in the maestro to maintain physiological
temperature and the ECM any
environmental control accessory that
helps to maintain co2 and physiological
pH and this is important as it allows
long-term recording by keeping
themselves in a stable environment and
this is particularly important because
the maestro and MEA technology provides
a label-free and non-invasive way to
measure the electric illogical changes
of the cells and what this means is that
the electrodes are not modifying the
biology when performing the measurement
such that measurements can be made over
the timescales of minutes hours days or
even weeks the other half of the
platform is the software which is the
axion integrated studio or access
software suite access provides a simple
and easy-to-use interface for both data
acquisition and analysis and will step
through some of the aspects of the
software that make it a stream lee
valuable tool the first is that you're
able to visualize data from every
electrode in the plate here we're seeing
raw data for each electrode within a
well this panel here illustrates the raw
activity of the raw voltage traits from
a single single electrode in addition
you're there flexible data visualization
options so that you can look at data not
just from the single raw trace but also
using this panel to visualize process
data and then the plate map
functionality for viewing all 768
electrodes at once in addition with
built-in configurations and simple
controls you're able to both acquire and
analyze data in a high through pet
fashion faster than ever before so now
I'd like to take a brief moment to go
through the raw voltage data and the
metrics that we're able to extract using
access from this data as we mentioned
before briefly the raw voltage data
reflects the electrophysiological
changes
that are that are occurring from each
cell located nearby the electrodes by
processing this data we're able to
detect single action potentials which
here the timing of the action potentials
is marked by the individual tick marks
in what's called a raster plot by simply
counting up these acts potentials or the
tick marks in this raster we're able to
compute a value called the mean firing
rate and this is a general estimate of
how active that particular neuron is and
we can go beyond just counting the
counting spikes in getting an overall
level of activity by understanding how
the spikes are grouped in time we're
here we're showing a rapid succession of
bursts a rapid succession of spikes in a
short period of time that is a burst or
call to burst once a burst has been
identified we're able to compute metrics
related to bursting such as the duration
and the frequency with which the verse
occur we can extend this across the full
multi-electrode array by looking at the
entire well in this case we have a well
raster where each of these lines in the
raster is similar is a reflection of a
single electrode within the array in
much the same way we did with single
electrode recordings we can compute
bursting activity including the duration
and frequency of the bursts that occur
across the entire array or the entire
network and also use quantitative
synchrony measures to understand fine
timescale coordination across across the
neurons within the well and axis
automatically computes all of these
neural endpoints making advanced
analysis simple and accessible and once
you have these neural endpoints you're
able to evaluate how particular
perturbations of the network influences
end points such as farm a lot
pharmacological manipulations or disease
and edition models so using these
metrics there's a number of applications
that are available
with the maestro neurotoxin including
neurotoxicity screen drug discovery and
functional disease models today in
particular were here about two example
disease models that have been
illustrated on the maestro platform so
far autism spectrum disorders and pain
in addition there's a number of other
disease models that have been
demonstrated on the maestro platform
ranging from Alzheimer's epilepsy to
schizophrenia if you'd like more
information on any of these disease
models that are not mentioned today or
in general about the maestro MEA
technology and its application to to
advancing neuroscience please visit the
product applications pages a taxi and
biosystems com and if you have any
additional questions please feel free to
contact us at info @ x and Viacom and
finally I'd like to introduce a few new
products that will be coming later this
year and that is an automation platform
for automated cell culture and
experimentation and also the Lumos a
multi-well light delivery device
designed specifically for optogenetic
applications Thank you Thank You Daniel
if you have questions for dr. milord
please submit them at any time I will
hold all the questions until after all
the speakers are finished next we'll
hear from dr. carol marketo a senior
staff scientist in the laboratory of dr.
fred gauge at the salk institute for
biological studies in la jolla
california carol is currently studying
the behavior of different subtypes of
human neurons and neurodevelopmental and
neuropsychiatric diseases such as autism
spectrum disorders and schizophrenia I
will now turn it over to dr. Machado for
her presentation about network level
signaling in an in vitro autism model
hello I'm camera title and I'd like to
thank accion by a system for inviting me
to talk to date and my brutes for
hosting this webinar and the attendees
they're listening to us now I would like
to start by giving you a little
background on our motivation to look for
alternative models to study neurological
diseases if you or someone
you know is diagnosed with a
neurodevelopmental neuropsychiatric or
neurodegenerative disease the likelihood
of having any effective drug available
in the market for you is really low the
reality is that approximately ninety
percent of drug candidates fail at
clinical trials due to issues in safety
and efficacy and one reason for the
failure of many drug candidates is the
human in the human system is the poor
productivity of the preclinical models
knowledge from others and that is to say
that existing models to test new
therapeutic compounds new door new drug
candidates are limited like most cells
of your body we cannot remove brain
cells from patients without causing
major consequence for marking tissues
like functional information and
represent the endpoint of the disease
leaving questions with regards to the
initiating your cause or events MRI
magnetic resonance imaging can provide
dynamic and functional information the
resolution is not enough to detect
single cell activity peripheral tissues
such as blood another target tissue were
the desert them any sense and finally
rodent models allow the sister do some
of the genetic components of the
disorder but a typical human behavior
components present in such such as
communication social impairments
illusions can't be devastated in the
ribbon model so we have the current feel
that combining reprogramming technology
with functional analysis provided by
platform such as the action
multi-electrode array technology can
provide additional information to the
previous model described and potentially
allow for better understanding of human
error logical disease biology and
potential discovery of new targets and
even testable drugs in the future today
specifically I will be telling you about
two promising studies in our lab where
we aim to model two different
neurological diseases in the first part
I'll show you that IPS derived models
from
inspector these are their patients or
idiopathic autism have already have
altered activity in the second part of
my talk I will show the data from our
attempt to model drug responsiveness in
vitro using IPS derived neurons from
patients with bipolar disorder so we use
a specific system in the lab to
differentiate marrow cells from patients
with autism we obtained biopsies from
eight autistic patients and five asian
gender matched controls from the group
of Eric who shares me from UCSD autism
and center for excellence we then
reprogram the lines into IPS and
subsequently differentiate them into
neurons via a neural progenitor
intermediate state when we probe the
neurons from mark we can probe the
neurons from markers for glutamatergic
synapses which are excitatory and
exemplified here by the glute one from
top and based on our previous work with
neural derived from red syndrome
patients but that were also included
under the umbrella of autistic spectrum
disorder we predicted that the
glutamatergic excitatory synapses could
be altered in idiopathic autism indeed
we have noticed a significant decrease
in the density of glutamatergic synapses
Bernie right lines in the ASD compared
to controls because you wanted to
simultaneously record the neuronal
activity from eight autistic patients
and tight controls we decided to turn to
the lucha lectures platform where we
could compare multiple cell lines at the
same time we the image show here from
here show the representatives buy
crestor plots from 10 channels from one
well plated with control cultures over
30 days and all 50 days after
differentiation as you can see control
lines have a tendency of increasing the
number of spikes which are those little
kicks individual tix that you see
in any channel in every channel and and
also they increase the bursts over time
to facilitate visualization and multiple
comparisons we collapsed all the spikes
from which from one channel and
superimpose further with a autism sample
this work was done in collaboration with
be afraid us and the Alison watches lab
Amy CSD when we over only over impose
the ASD derived neural networks to the
control we notice that a 30 days of
differentiation we could already
detected tendency for decreased activity
of ASD Miriam's at 50 days after
differentiation we detected a
significant decrease in both spike
number as well as network posts defined
here as a sequence of ten spikes over
100 milliseconds we then asked if we
were able to rescue the neuron activity
death cities in autism insulin growth
factor called our attention for a couple
of reasons as a candidate for wrestling
effect insulin ijevin had been shown to
improve rett syndrome defective
phenotypes in mouse model and patient
neurons in vitro and also igf-1 has
already shown in vitro in vivo energy
when also as Jeff one he's already used
being used in clinical trials for
idiopathic autism red syndrome felon
mcdermott syndrome and fragile X we then
treated our decided to treat our
colonies our differentiating neurons
risk igf-1 and we added I just one on
day 58 of the differentiation we did a
detective positive effect of igf-1
treatment in asd cells partially
rescuing the decreased neuron activity
interestingly there seems to be a
differentiation response to a GF when
treatment specific to different patients
indicating the possibility of patient
tailored therapies as you can see here
in the bottom panel grass different
lines colors represent different
autistic patients Abel arch our client
arrow are just a fictional names for our
patients and as you can see Abel the
black and the red arrow respond
differently to igf-1 treatment compared
to the yellow and the blue arch and our
alliance so in summary for part one AST
derived neurons show decreased
connectivity in vitro we showed with us
reduced synaptogenesis altered levels of
excitatory neurotransmitters functional
defects in neural network that can be
selectively rescue resides f1 the aft in
vitro model could be used to study
difference in the renomination during
critical period in autism that could not
be feasible to study during human
development the model we think could
review potential biomarkers for
diagnosis as well as information and
appreciate at a pre-symptomatic stage
and could be potentially used for drug
screening next we turned into to study
another neuropsychiatry diseases which
has very little treatment available and
this is bipolar disorder we generated in
the lab IPS is from fibroblasts from
bipolar patients that were responsive or
non-responsive to lithium treatment and
from controls the humanism is one of the
few drugs used for bipolar disorder and
worked as a mood stabilizer and our
patients were screened and biopsies were
performed and the dis provision of John
Kelso in SSD we then use the protocol
that we
previously developed in the lab a
modified differentiation protocol to
generate an enriched population of
dentate gyrus granule cells neurons
using a combination of anti catalyzing
sectors and enrichment for those of for
brain with this protocol we were able to
enrich for population of the entire iris
neurons and we developed a reporter that
allowed us to visualize live people can
program only granule neurons and the
reporter consists of a viral vector
containing a dented specific promoter
which is called prox 1 and expresses a
green fluorescent protein so we can
visualize the integers neurons in the
cultures we then previously in the lab
work from juniel and jerome martins
showed that it will camp odd integers
neurons derived from bipolar patients
have hyperexcitability by
electrophysiology and this is shown here
by a decrease in action potential
threshold in B moreover those cells the
bipolar cells both Legion responsive and
non-responsive showed lower trash so
show an increased number of evoked
action potentials those are sample
traces of current injection evokes our
operations in the bottom and
additionally the two bi polar groups
were able to had hyperexcitability and
only the lesion treatment reversed only
hyper hyper activity in the bipolar
patients in responsive group but not in
the non responsive group showing in the
bottom to grasp we then wanted to
confirm the observations that we made
with traditional platform techniques and
also look at I namak change in the
network or a generals or
time so we used an Emmy a system for a
pilot experiment we started the
recording as early as five days after
differentiation and detected a sharp
increase a sharp increase in the spike
number at day nine confirming the early
hyperexcitability phenotype on BD
patients previously detected in a field
we then treated the cells with Libyan on
day 12 and we wanted to see if we could
recover the hyperexcitability
selectively in responsive patients and
important to point out here we perform
those experiments in 96-well plate I
mean if Excel plate which allows us to
have a lot of replicate to test we then
looked at to our surprise we wanted to
do a time course after lithium treatment
and to our surprise only three hours
after lesion treatment exposure was
sufficient to decrease the number of
spikes on listing responsive but not
only ting non-responsive cells as shown
here in the bottom bar graph the same
effect was carry on after 24 hours of
lithium treatment we are currently
investigating how long do the facts were
last but none of the less our
preliminary data indicated that MEA
technology could be used to probe
patient drug responsiveness in summary
in part two we show that
hyperexcitability bipolar disorder
nerves from bipolar disorder patients
across very early before even to expose
differentiation in both leading
responsive and non-responsive patients
and living with bags on the hyper
excitability phenotype is detected only
on linking responsive self as stressed
as three hours after drug addition these
results are encouraging to develop a
functional assay for drug testing
using the reduction of the hybrid
acceptability that we've semen bipolar
neurons as a readout and I like to close
acknowledging Fred gage lab and Fred
gage specifically Renato central zero
Matins Ruth author and an Amanda's were
directly involved in this project that I
talked about her collaborator
collaborators Alison watching and be
afraid of the necessity Kristen Brennan
in Montana hospital New York every
crucial mankind Pierce and UCSD Autism
Center for Excellence juniel in some
graphs University China and John careful
in 50 and many thanks for that you for
watching SS thank you dr. Marchetta for
that interesting presentation now we are
from dr. john graves a senior research
investigator at bristol-myers squibb in
connecticut you focused on using
multi-electrode array platform to
develop in vitro efficacy assays from
multiple discovery program i will now
turn it over to dr. grace for his
presentation on an modeling root
ganglion stone all right thanks Stacey
for that introduction and thank you
accion in lab roots for organizing this
webinar so today what I want to focus on
the last part of this webinar is art how
we've been using this MEA system for
Maxie on to basically try to create a
pain in a dish model using embryonic rat
dorsal root ganglion neurons so Daniel
did a nice job giving an overview of the
NBA system and what what the
capabilities are so I won't belabor
these few introductory slides too much
but I wanted to show just an example of
one well of drg activity in the lower
right hand corner they're showing
real-time spontaneous activity from drg
neurons and what this looks like across
the whole place this would be a 48 well
mea plate and you can see by this heat
map as activity pops up in real time
across the MEA play
so in danielle's did a nice job showing
the types of metrics that can be pulled
out from the mea recordings and I just
want to basically reiterate here how at
least in my view how valuable all these
different metrics can be so since a
priori you don't know exactly what
metric is going to be the most relevant
when comparing different conditions or
different cell types it's nice to be
able to pull out all these different
metrics and look at them post hoc and
find out what might be the most relevant
one and so this is just showing again
from a single spike train all the
different measurements you can pull out
from those individual spikes as well as
the burst characteristics and Daniel
also mentioned that we can look at
network analysis so again looking at
synchronous activity cross correlation
and quantifying Network burst is also an
important aspect of how these different
networks interact and another thing I
wanted to highlight two is something
that we've been also looking at into is
terms of functional connections and so
here we're actually looking at
significantly correlated individual
neurons or electrodes looking at those
functional connections I'm saying how
those change over time and then also
looking at this propagation speed
between these connections is another
potential metric of potential phenotype
for in different conditions so when we
started doing this work a lot of this
our analysis was done before axiom came
out with their nice neuronal analysis
program so we had use our own custom
MATLAB analysis program and what we're
doing here is we're actually taking the
spike files which can be exported from
the acts of software and this basically
gives you information on when the spike
occurs in the waveform of that spike and
so you can extrapolate on the type of
metrics or data from that from that
spike file so we would import it into
our analysis program and then export CSV
files and then read this into a program
called Spotfire for data visualization
and this allowed us to basically look at
how these metrics change over time
easily and do multi parametric analysis
to see how the different metrics how
they're affected in different cell types
or different treatment conditions and
another thing that we've had we've
started doing especially with the drg
neurons is actually doing some spikes
sorting based upon amplitude and so
sometimes you get because there's drgs
like like to cluster around electrodes
you'll get multiple neurons firing on
one electrode and to be able to sort
these spikes out individually based upon
their amplitude is allowed us to get a
more sort of clean up our data in terms
of the the variability that we sometimes
see and we can look at how those
individual units are being affected over
time and just to kind of show you what
the comparison looks like so this we
went back and reanalyze some of our data
using our custom outlet program with the
the newer accion neural metrics program
and there's a very nice over light
between these two in terms of the
metrics looking here in terms of cross
correlation and also identifying bursts
and verse rain so there's a nice
correlation between these two these two
analysis programs suggesting that the
data that is being analyzed in a similar
fashion so now jumping into our assay so
as I mentioned before we wanted to
basically create a pain in a dish model
using these dorsal root ganglion and so
these drg neurons basically they are
clustered within a gangling or the cell
bodies within a gangling outside the CNS
alongside the spinal cord as you can see
here of the wrong one as you can see
here so
and so basically the role that these drg
neurons plays to transmit sensory
information from the periphery along the
axon to the cell body and then into the
central nervous system of the spinal
cord and the dorsal horn of the spinal
cord and transmit that information up
into up into the brain and as you can
see from this cartoon up in this review
there are several different ion channels
involved in propagating and integrating
these signals along the drg up into the
brain and so there are a lot of
different potential targets here that
can be different channels that can be
targeted for for potential pain
neuropathic pain States and so that
these drg neurons they exhibit little
spontaneous activity under normal
conditions however following nerve
injury or inflammation is where we start
to see hyperexcitability or ectopic
spontaneous discharges which can be
transmitted to the spinal cord in the
brain signaling pain when payments and
president is this can underline certain
neuropathic States and so really our
goal here was to using the MUA system
create spontaneously active or
hyperactive dorsal root ganglia in a
disc so we can then use we can then look
at different targets within these drg
neurons and see how well certain
compounds are at inhibiting this
spontaneous activity so early attempts
at looking at the activity word were not
too successful so the animations you see
here is just with evoked activity so we
were able to evoke activity with some
trip channel agonist such as cap station
and methanol and you can see there the
the activity that was invoked but we
really were not able to see any
spontaneous activity it's several
different plating densities and once we
elicited activity the spontaneous
segment any that activity was no longer
present after an initial you know 30
seconds to a minute so this wasn't a
very good
a stay at first to try to test the
effects of different compounds and so we
wanted to work on developing this aspect
so we can get robust spontaneous
activity and and I'll walk you the next
few slides what we did to to recreate
that now we also the next step was to
actually add nerve growth factor ngf to
the cultures and as you can see here
this did lead to small amounts of
variable spontaneous activity this is
from a 12-well plate and you can see
just small bits of spontaneous activity
popping up by the heat map and again
this was not this was not ideal so the
next step we did was to actually look at
adding some antimitotic agents to
prevent Swann cell proliferation and to
kind of help the DRG stay in here and
not come off of the mea plate I miss did
lead to an increase in the number of
active electrodes that we were picking
up on the MEA we were able to induce
more activity with a non-selective
potassium channel blockers to further
depolarized the drg neurons for AP and
this did increase activity to a certain
extent but this we still did not feel
this is ideal in terms of having a big
enough window in terms of activity that
we could push the activity higher or
push the activity lower to kind of
really test the effects of either
inhibiting or increasing spontaneous
activity within the drg drg cells and so
really what it kind of came down to was
just we just added a little salt to our
culture's and what we had noticed is
that we were culturing in standard neuro
basal medium we were recording in neuro
basal medium and the sodium chloride
concentration and neuro basil was was
relatively low compared to what is
typically used in other artificial CSF
preps or what's physiologically relevant
and so just by supplementing our own
basil medium with some sodium chloride
bringing the concentration up to a more
relevant a hundred and forty million
molar concentration we were able to get
really robust spontaneous activity which
you can kind of see here on the lower
left
on the heat map getting nice activity in
all wells of the 12 well plate and this
did persist over time so you can see on
the graph in the lower right hand corner
starting at div 11 is stands for days in
vitro so this is 11 days in culture we
have robust activity which seems to last
out past past two weeks and so here we
finally felt that we had a nice robust
ass a good spontaneous activity in our
drgs and now we were able to actually go
in and pro the underlying channels and
receptors that were involved in the
spontaneous activity and how we could
target those to either reduce that
activity or to increase it and so as far
as another development aspect we looked
at different plating densities and so
when we sort of optimized our culture
conditions we were able to plate at
lower plating densities and can still
get good spontaneous activity so here
you can see a density dependent increase
in active electrodes and spontaneous
activity as we're just covering more of
the MEA grit and you can see in the
upper at the inset in the upper right
hand corner a nice picture of the the
MEA grid the individual electrode here
and then you can also see individual
dorsal root ganglion right here and so
this is what 50,000 drgs / well played
in directly on top of the electrode were
able to get nice activity and this looks
and look like a good a good asset to
move forward with so and just kind of
quantifying this over time looking at
different plating densities we can see
that the activity does increase over
time from starting at four days in vitro
all the way out to two weeks in vitro
and again this is just in the table at
the bottom this kind of quantifies all
the different metrics that we were that
we were looking at and so you can see
that we get a pretty decent amount of
active electrodes /
mea we're about half of our electrodes
are picking up spontaneous activity the
spike rate once we do the actual spike
sorting it's it's not that you know it's
a fired about one you know one hurt so
they're not firing at high rates like
you might see with hippocampal zor
cortical cultures and also in contrast
to hippocampal and cortical cultures you
can see here in terms of the
connectivity the cross-correlation
probability and the the functional
network connections below that that
these dr g's really aren't networked up
there sort of autonomous neurons and
just just firing mostly in a tonic state
just firing single axe potentials but
they do have some bursting activity
which you can see here it's not that
much we got about three births per
minute on average from these drg neurons
so essentially they're not forming
functional synaptic connections we're in
a hippocampal of cortical neuron culture
you would you would typically see that
but these they're forming gangling and
then they're just there spontaneously
firing action potentials and in more of
a tonic manner instead of in the end of
instead of bursting and then so the next
few slides we basically decided to a
whole lot of pharmacology to really
profile these drgs these embryonic rat
drgs on the MUA system to see what
channels are involved in the spontaneous
activity what channels can be targeted
how can we increase this activity and
you can see here using the trip v1
agonist capsaicin that we do have a nice
dose response in terms of increasing the
doses of capsaicin will lead to
increasing spike rates on the right-hand
side you can see here so again this is
comparing the just straightener Oh basil
media versus the spike neural basil
media with sodium chloride and you can
see comparing the two gray bars there at
37 degrees Celsius physiological
temperature that there is that increase
in activity and we do have the neuro
basil spike for sodium
we can increase the temperature so this
the MUA system does have his temperature
controlled we can increase the
temperature and activate the trip be one
receptor and we do see a nice increase
in activity as well so you're just a
couple of examples of how we can even
boost the spontaneous activity even
further are the overall activity right
even further we next wanted to look at
again the different ion channels
involved in this activity and so first
of all we wanted to look at sodium
channels and so it's been shown that drg
have both TTX tetrodotoxin resistant and
tetrodotoxin sensitive nav and so we
wanted to look at how TTX affected the
spontaneous activity within these
cultures and we looked at two different
time points early on at seven days and
culture or seven div and then it two
weeks in culture and you can see it's
seven days in culture that's the light
gray circles and figure in panel a that
it does show a nice dose response in
terms of inhibiting its activity and
that this shifts to the left becoming
more potent at 14 days suggesting that
these t.t expensive channels have a
greater contribution to the spontaneous
activity as the cultures mature and just
to kind of make a make ourselves feel
good we wanted to record do a wholesale
patch recording from an emmy a plate and
so we use the mea to identify a fairly
active drg neurons we went in and we
patched the cell and you can see the
results of that are in panel B at
baseline we can again we can see that
there is nice spontaneous action
potentials that are popping up at
baseline and again we can block this
with TTX basic validating that we are
picking up action potentials in bit 42x
sensitive on the MEA we next wanted to
try to tease apart the different
subtypes that are involved in certain
cell types that are involved in the
spontaneous activity the TTX sensitive
subtypes being 13 1.6 1.7 where the TTX
resistant being
1.8 1.9 and and and so our first
experiment was to look at pro-thaksin 2
and this is a peptide isolated from
tarantula venom which is supposedly
selective for nav 1.7 and at this
concentration of 10 animal which you can
see here in panel c and so kind of in
line with a results from panel a early
on pro-thaksin two is not did not do as
well of a job inhibiting spontaneous
activity but at two days at two weeks in
culture we see that there is a nice
inhibition of activity suggesting that
the 1.7 subunit has a greater
contribution at later time points in the
culture we also wanted to look at nav
1.8 at ETX resistant channel and again
here using this compound a 803 467 which
is selective for nav 1.8 you can see at
an earlier time point seven days in
culture that light gray bars it's a
fairly potent with an ic50 of around 150
mana molar however at a later time point
this is it is it's shifted to the right
suggesting it's not as potent with the
nicely 50 greater than a micro molar and
this might be non non selective effects
out here so again this this lines up
with TTX resistant channels having more
of a contribution early on TTX sensitive
channels having more of a contribution
as these cultures mature we also want to
look at calcium channels and so here we
looked at both high threshold calcium
channels which are n l and r type
calcium channels as well as low
threshold calcium channels for t-type
calcium channels as you can see here in
panel a we looked at both we looked at
nuh feta pain in a couple different
concentrations and l-type calcium
channel which did not have much of an
effect at 393 micromolar but was able to
inhibit activity at 10 micro molar we
looked at the n-type selective toxin
peptide kind of toxin MV MV m7a and you
can see here that at one micromolar and
three micromolar there was not much of
an effect
n-type and the same thing with the art
type the snx 482 peptide and again you
can see there's not much of an effect
with with these with these compounds and
so this the 10 micro molar effect with
nymphetamine was probably could
potentially do to affect the t-type
calcium channels because at these higher
concentrations instead opinion does seem
that does have an effect on t-type
calcium channels and so that was our
next couple experiments we wanted to see
look specifically at these low threshold
t-type calcium channels in in panel B
you can see the better deal which is a
selective t-type calcium channel blocker
is able to fully inhibit the spontaneous
activity and the drg neurons as well as
nickel chloride also is able to actually
inhibit network bursts so remember they
don't burst as much but we are able to
inhibit a first rate with nickel
chloride which is more selective with
cap 3.2 subtype so from this we
basically concluded that the the high
threshold calcium channels were not
involved in much into spontaneous
activity words the t-type calcium
channels were we also looked at
potassium channel compounds as well so
lino pyridine which is an mm channel
blocker this flux p.m. current the
potassium M current you can see the nice
dose response here in terms of
increasing activity you can see that
these these cells become very active
when you increase concentrations of Lena
pyridine as well as with for IP data
that was kind of shown earlier and you
can see the the increase and activity
with with the for AP application and so
here again just demonstrating that we
can increase activity with potassium
channel blockers
and quickly just wanted also that these
hcn channels are have also been shown to
play a role in drg excitability we
looked at one in particular ZD seven to
eight eight and you can see it does have
an effect on spontaneous activity
whereas this you know these results
could be confounded with potential
effects on nav channels which had been
shown in earlier slides to decrease
activity so again this these were a
little hard to interpret it but at
higher concentrations you can see out
here this might potentially be due to
effects on hcn channel so they may may
play a role as well with drg
excitability and in this in this press
so moving on from ion channels to actual
receptors and we wanted to look at the
sort of the neurotransmitter profile
within these cultures and so obvious the
first things we wanted to examine where
the effects of glutamate and gaba in
these cultures and so if you focus on
the bottom right-hand graph here you can
see that the effects of gaba glutamate
and NMDA and the red green and brown
respectively really had no effect on
activity whereas we if we applied
bradykinin this had a rather robust
increase in activity the effects of
substance p is well an orange or shounen
which also did not have an effect on
increasing activity so the korlah to
this looking at the antagonists for
these receptors if we focus on the red
green and brown bars right here again
this lines up nicely with no effect of
actual Gavin glutamate or NMDA
application we similar do not see an
effect of those respective and taggants
for those receptors we did see what was
interesting though we use some neuro
kind and one and two antagonists which
actually completely abolished activity
as you can see here so it looks like sub
substance p as a neural keinen ligon you
can add substance p you don't see
tivity increase in activity but if you
add the antagonist to these receptors
you completely abolish it so let you
know suggesting that the culture means
sort of already saturated with some sort
of neuro condom ligon and you able to
decrease basically inhibit activity by
blocking those receptors it's also
interesting to see that with a
bradykinin abby to bradykinin receptor
antagonist specifically that we don't
see much of an effect here suggesting
there are any really functional Brady
konnen to receptors I mean I'm
suggesting that there's really no
bradykinin within and dodges for any
kind of within this culture and it's
only once it's you added exotically do
you see a robust increase in activity
levels so we wanted to also kind of
probe using bradykinin as an insult or a
to these cultures to really increase
activity so that's what this is showing
here on this slide and so we'll just
focus here on this bottom graph and so
you can see under control conditions we
see again a nice robust increase with
Brady kalian one micromolar bradykinin
if we pretreat with these different
compounds that can block activities such
as retic of being which actually is a
potassium channel opener to
hyperpolarize themselves and you can see
the dose-response there in the upper
right-hand corner this inhibits activity
and then if you add rated kinda we
really do not see that robust increase
in activity same thing with the
substance with the neuro keinen
antagonist and with PTX once you inhibit
spontaneous activity with these with
these compounds you really cannot induce
activity with bradykinin it's also
interesting to see that the brady kind
of to selectively antagonists wins 6 4 3
38 at one micromolar partially blocks
the the brady kind of induced activity
and a 10 micro molar basically what we
can see here is that we're fully
inhibiting the Brady kind and induced
activity without affecting sort of
underlining spontaneous activity which
lines up what we saw previously so you
can
fully block this brady kind of evoked
activity with this that b 2 receptor
antagonist and it's finally so in order
to kind of validate this model for for
pain you know we looked at some
different compounds that have been used
in the clinic for for pain such as
carbamazepine amitriptyline in deland
duloxetine and you can see here in the
upper right upper left-hand corner that
we do see nice dose responses with these
three compounds they're able to inhibit
spontaneous activity we also looked at
gabapentin which is shown on the right
hand side this did have you know did
have a significant effect at a high
concentration of one milli molar
starting at 24 hours and at four days
post so this lends some credence to this
assay being used to characterize
different pain Therapeutics you'll
notice in the table at the bottom here
we did look at morphine in this had no
effect and this kind of lines up with
morphine acting more centrally for it
for its analgesic effect and so that
lines up with what we were when we were
looking at just a metapopulation drg
neurons that make sense in this assay
and one final thing I just wanted to
notice a lot of our compounds that we
look at we do have to dissolve in DMSO
but what was interesting is DMSO itself
can an acutely increase activity and you
kind of kind of see that there as we add
VMs of an animation we get a nice robust
I'll be a transient increase in activity
but if you look about 20-30 minutes post
DMSO and we did serial editions of
different concentrations of DMSO you can
see that it does tend to return to
baseline so you can get a good read on
the effects of compounds if you have to
add in DMSO after about 20 30 minutes
and so well that's that's all I had and
to kind of summarize what you know what
we don't sass a you know we basically
optimized it to get good spontaneous
activity of these drg neurons we see
optimal activity anywhere from
one-and-a-half to two weeks in culture
at about 50,000 cells per well for
actual MEA they should they show you can
you can both in
and inhibit activity with different
different ion channel blockers as well
as different peptides and that this
activity can be blocked by compounds
that have been used in the clinic for
chronic pain and so this does represent
in a platform with a physiologically
relevant and you know functional in
vitro paint a say that can be used for
characterizing compounds and so I think
we're going to kind of want to harp on
the point that this really is looking at
endogenous excitability within within
these drgs since there doesn't seem to
be much neurotransmitter release
anything that's going to target that
that's that pathway in the spinal cord
for neurotransmitter release such as
these higher threshold calcium channels
would not be expected to have an effect
as we showed but this really is looking
at intrinsic excitability of the drgs
and how you can actually target that to
reduce spontaneous activity and
hopefully reduce ectopic pain discharges
and with that my final slide just want
to acknowledge the people here that help
with this work at BMS which are shown
there and also acknowledge you know
Daniel accion and Matthew Brock as well
who also helped early days it accion
with with a lot of this you know assay
development and data analysis so with
that I'll conclude alright thank you
John for that interesting presentation
before we get started on the question
and answer session I just want to remind
everyone how to submit the question of
you can submit your question by typing
them in the Q&A box which you can find
on the by clicking the green Q&A button
at the lower left we'll try to answer as
many questions as we can so our first
question here is a general question
about assistance which I'm going to
direct to dr. Millard is MEA and this my
stress system applicable only to cell
culture or also to brain slices
it's a great question and while it is
possible to perform slice based
experiments particularly in the 12 volt
format where there are larger wells in
general the maestro was designed for
cell culture with the goal in mind of
significantly increasing the throughput
with which customers could get at
answers to the scientific questions okay
thank you this next question is for dr.
Machado did you find that the MEA data
correlates well with single cell action
potential data especially considering
the heterogeneity of the cells and so
Perry food potential with great
questions Perry we've been trying to
tackle that problem for oh I don't know
and we are recruiting a few
computational biologists in our lab to
try to combine data sets from those two
different sources combining pairing food
potential with single action potential
is challenging especially for human
events because exactly the heterogeneity
and however our patch clamping data
compared from bipolar disease patients
comparing with the feud potentials from
bipolar indicates that at least
everything is moving into the same trend
so I can't answer you precisely and now
but we we think that they are correlated
as far as we can tell right now that we
are still investigating it further all
right thank you this next one is again
for dr. Miller does the MEA discriminate
activity from excitatory versus
inhibitory neurons
this is another great question and that
many of the types of neural cultures
that people are interested in on the MEA
do involve mixed populations of cell
types in particular cortical neurons
cortical neuron cultures have a
significant amount of both excitatory
and inhibitory components I'll answer
this question in in two different ways
the first is that the bursting activity
an overall network activity in general
from well is reflective of the relative
contributions of excitatory and
inhibitory neurons and how they
contribute to the activity so an example
of this is that in a cortical neuron
culture you might have a burst of
activity and if you used a
pharmacological agent to inhibit the
inciter inhibitory components of that
network you find often that the burst
duration has increased and if we think
that is intuitively it's because the
inhibitory population within the network
isn't able to do its job which is to
shut down the burst of activity once the
excitatory neurons start the burst so
this is a simplistic example to
illustrate that many of the metrics we
discussed related to bursting and
synchrony are directly reflective of the
relative contributions of the excitatory
and inhibitory neurons within
populations and the second I'll try and
keep this brief but we mentioned the
Lumos which is a new multi-well light
delivered device that will be later
available later this year which
incorporates optogenetics I won't go
into the details of optiv genetics but
for those that are aware it's a tool
that would allow you to selectively
activate potentially one cell type
versus another and in this case
excitatory versus inhibitory neurons in
this way the Lumos would it would be
possible to activate selectively just
the excitatory neurons identify which
electrodes are detecting those responses
and then use that moving forward in your
analysis to isolate those two distinct
cell populations
alright great Thank You Daniel this next
one is for dr. graves a couple of
similar questions here where our
audience is wondering if you're able to
isolate single units from the multi-unit
activity at each electrode and kind of
in conjunction with that what is the
diversity of your young drg neurons
spell type you do you know the
distribution of subtypes in your systems
and can you tell the different effects
on different subtypes with your
pharmacological manipulation yeah no
that would be great I wish I did so yeah
this is a very heterogeneous population
of cells the DRG small medium large
diameter peptidergic namitha dyrdek and
we don't have a way to to do that right
now other than what Dan was talking
about earlier to do different to
transduce in different cell types and
then and then stimulate there so no we
don't really know what what cell type
you know we're looking at and we haven't
really investigated looking at the
actual firing properties or the
extracellular waveform properties and
see if that correlates with a certain
cell type and as far as trying to get
single unit so you know I can't really
say that we are actually getting you
know we are really discriminating
between all the units on the electrode
and so basically we're doing a crude
spike sorting in terms of amplitude
right now and based in what dictates how
large the amplitude is is based upon how
proximity to the actual electrode and so
two electrodes that are you know same
proximity or two cells are in the same
proximity to the electorate probably
have a similar spike amplitude
potentially and so we can't really say
we're actually discriminate between
single units but we try to in those
clear-cut cases to discriminate between
individual units okay good thank you
this next one is for dr. marketo are you
sorting your spell's or enrichment or
hand selecting based on the GSP reporter
and also are you adding any Lea and how
do you cope the plate before
laying down a cell and requests we are
not yet selecting them on the jetty
reporter for the agreements that I have
shown we are starting to sort them into
in the next follow-up increments just to
study specific subtypes of neurons
isolated when we do that we would add
glia on the bottom as coating and we
also caught the plates with poly honest
in Lebanon and that has been a general
coating described in the literature and
we currently we don't use Korea but as
soon as we would start cells the cells
budan necessary since I is very healthy
without degree and the reason why we
don't start for a degree right now is
because our populations have
differentiated from their progenitor
cells in the mea plates have already a a
Pacific percentage of glia cells there
that is constant okay thank you and this
next question is for dr. graves our
compound activities comparable in
recombinant cells versus the RG culture
on MEA versus in vivo oh yeah that's
that's a great question to a certain
extent yes so I in recombinant cells if
you're looking in a particular channel
and so the potency gun that channel in a
recombinant cell doesn't always track to
the drg and again because what you're
you're measuring and the MEA is just
spontaneous activity and so your IC 50
value at that individual channel may not
necessarily correlate with an ic50 value
for effects on spontaneous activity
sometimes it can be more potent in the
dr gsa and sometimes it can be less
potent depending upon how how it's you
know how it's expressed within the DRG
and how it interacts with other channels
to
you know to contribute to the underlying
excitability as far as in vain again in
vivo we do you know we see similar
similarities across all three of those
platforms in terms of what works on one
tends to work on you know you know in
MEA as well as in vivo it's just a
matter of potency and probably that's
just a matter of you know whether it's
getting getting to the target and
another you know PK properties that are
involved in vivo but yeah for the most
part there is nice there is nice
alignment across recombinant cells DRG
nmea and and in vivo Hey thank you well
that's all the time we have for right
now so i would like to once again thank
dr. miller dr Marketo and dr. grace for
their presentations today and we'd also
like to thank our sponsor accion
biosystems for making today's webcast
possible if we didn't get to your
question today we will receive the full
list of questions within 24 hours and
we'll follow up with a reply to your
question by the end of the week also
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 7 2016
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when the webcast is
available for you to replay so we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live events and you can submit
additional questions when replaying the
webcast using that same screen Q&A
button at the lower left we will reply
to those questions via email so thank
you again for your attendance and we'll
see you next time